j'apporte des lions a' de descamps à
magnésie noix de pécan qu elle fait des
tartes aux 9 déc emmène roja bhl je
plains ce pauvre mari
il bélanger bonjour salut bienvenus vous
êtes un des directeurs de la
photographie les plus en vue en ce
moment tout d'abord comment vous
expliquez votre ascension des dernières
années
la chance d'être là au bon moment des
choses comme ça jean marc vallée vous
avez dollars l'aviez de vaines il ya
aussi clint eastwood ou monsieur c'est
arrivé plus tard on va en parler
justement mais avant qu'est ce que c'est
un directeur photo médias photos c'est
la personne qui est responsable
de l'image du film donc deux shows
j'appelle tout à la fin de la chaîne
alimentaire
j'enregistre tout ce que les autres
départements ont fait plus de la
performance des acteurs a fait que c'est
contrôler l'éclairage les cadrages et
tout toujours sous la direction du
réalisateur c'est sur
votre passion pour le cinéma a débuté à
l'âge de 8 ans un électrochoc vous avez
vu 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace de stanley
kubrick
quel impact ce film a eu sur votre vie
est belle fille avant puis après je me
souviens déjà enfant j'avais j'étais
fasciné par les images mais j'ai eu
carrément une sensation physique
comme ça rentrait pas juste pas réussir
vos mutuelles andré par le corps et
après c'était je me souviens c'était une
sensation physique comme acteur photo
moi c'est ma plus rose influence puisque
kubrick comme beaucoup de cinéastes
de grands cinéastes surtout ceux qui ont
commencé
avant les années 50 il contrôlait
carrément la technique l'image de
montage
- caen mâcon vraiment ma plus grande
influence de direction photo sipa un
adapteur photo systémique ce n'est pas
chez ge ge est censé connaître votre
carrière a commencé en quelque sorte
avec chéri mais le grand décollage tant
2012 avec leurs enseignants et de
dollars le film dallas buyers club a
vraiment été votre entrée à du film de
jean marc vallée que son dessin est
ébranlé tout le québec - secteur 2
professionnel et personnel comment vous
avez vécu ça ben en état de choc là je
suis pas encore je n'ai pas encore prêt
à cesser comme comme on dit en québécois
je me suis très occupé je me suis occupé
beaucoup d autres mais
je sais pas trop y penser de régir et
pas à la saint gelven boules parce que
ça me rappelle trop lui c'est vraiment
lui qui me fait connaître le sens j'ai
fait qu on est là on essaie bains
hérault de faire que ça mais moi
continue tout le vécu d'un gros là
dedans y'a rien sur cette terre qui
puisse tuer ron woodroof au 30 juin
comex qui vous la chine il y avait entre
vous et jean marc vallée parce qu'à
l'écran ça fonctionnait puis à la
réalisation du voit la direction photo
dans des bars comme dans des séries télé
comme règle de droit - jean-marc joly
connu
il y avait fait quelques courts métrages
puis il commence à faire de la pub puis
nous avait jumelé ensemble c'est en 91
si on est devenu à nivet texte un ennemi
puis notre chimie pastore très différent
quand même le comme personnalité mais y
avait un gros respect l'un pour l'autre
moi c'était
jeudi même c'était super dur tourner une
recrue c'était sa demande et de la
concentration c'était s'était pas fait
dans la joie et le bonheur là et on
était vraiment en train de travailler
mais j'aime j'aime ça parce que je
savais qu'en salle à trouver quelque
chose de
2,2 merveilleux je pensais qu'il fallait
avant tout d'être quelqu'un dans la vie
parallèlement votre travail avec votre
ami jean marc vallée vous avez aussi
travaillé avec votre idole qui s'ouvre
sur deux fils tout d'abord c'était la
muse lui ensuite le cas richard joue
comment ça s'est passé avec clint
eastwood comme avec tout le monde un
timide a carrément votre idole gpat
intimider seulement séquence est arrivée
au bureau de deux mètres sur deux on
était dans une petite salle on
l'attendait paiement déjà entendu sans
menez puis le regarder comme des chiens
c'est signifie puis s'était fait rester
correct il faut juste qu'elle soit vraie
table ne pas être impressionné vous avez
travaillé avec l'école que du monde sur
le beagle au live oui et c'est elle qui
vous aurait demandé de revenir pour la
nouvelle série 9 parfait étranger ou un
c'est vrai ça oui mais comment dire si
souvent un effet domino dans ce sens que
nicole voulait moins mais ça a donné
bien parce que le réalisateur engagé
j'avais fait lang choc avec lui il
voulait de toute façon non mais ce que
c'est nicole qui a appelé le dire
arrivent non
il appelle l'agent
maintenu à ce niveau là il y appelle les
gens m'appellent des fois mes propos
pour la job directement et bélanger je
dois vous laisser parce que vous avez
des valises afin de partir en angleterre
deux mois pour l'autre tournage merci
beaucoup merci ça fait plaisir bon une
claquette de faim ouais normal on l'a
fait à l'envers mais